en la gráfica siguiente traza los ceros
reales del polinomio dado y nos dan este
polinomio pd x es igual a 2x alak
internas
x a la cuarta menos 2 x menos 1 y bueno
esencialmente lo que hacemos es le damos
clic en cualquier punto de esta gráfica
y nos aparecen puntitos nos podemos
desplazar como nosotros queramos y si ya
no los queremos los podemos tirar a este
basurero y desaparezca así que bien nos
preguntan dónde están los ceros o que
tracemos los ceros reales de este
polinomio de este polinomio de aquí así
que déjenme saco mi libreta para anotar
entonces tenemos que considerar los
ceros de este polinomio de aquí y bueno
es un polinomio de grado 5 así que igual
y esto se ve algo intimidante factorizar
cosas de grado mayor a 2 generalmente es
más un arte que una ciencia exacta pero
bueno vamos a ver si realmente quieren
que que hagamos esto sin la ayuda de una
calculadora o de una computadora
entonces debe haber algún patrón en este
polinomio veamos déjenme le escribo el
polinomio
escribo px p v x es igual a 2 x a la
quinta 2x a la quinta más x a la cuarta
si quizá la cuarta menos 2x menos 1
y bien vamos a ver quiero encontrar un
patrón este polinomio y esencialmente lo
que quiero hacer es utilizar la
propiedad distributiva varias veces
comenzamos por observar que si me fijo
en este primer caso en estos primeros
dos términos es 2 x x a una potencia más
x a una potencia de un grado menor y acá
también tengo un patrón similar aquí
tengo menos 2 x x a la 1 menos uno que
puedo pensar como x a la cero o sea x a
la potencia un grado menor así que
veamos vamos a reescribir esto déjenme
voy a voy a reescribir esto voy a
factorizar este primer caso como el
término de grado más alto que tienen en
común es x a la cuarta así que lo puede
escribir como x a la cuarta por 2 por x
más 1 que ya de hecho se parece bastante
a este cacho de acá así que voy a tomar
este cacho y de hecho lo que voy a hacer
es factorizar un -1 voy a factorizar un
-1 y escribir
menos 1 x 2 x + 1
así que al menos ya tengo este término
en común este término
y este término que puedo factorizar para
sacar de la expresión traerlos al frente
y escribir esto como
2 x 1
2 x 1 que multiplica
que multiplica pues sin factores en 2 x
1 aquí me queda un x a la cuarta menos 1
muy bien ahora aquí tengo una diferencia
de cuadrados y voy a escribir esto como
pues veamos 2 x 1 los dejo así 2 x 1 y
esto lo comenzó en la diferencia de
cuadrados lo voy a expresar como
x al cuadrado más 1 x x al cuadrado
menos 1
bien vamos progresando ya casi lo
tenemos en una forma reducida dejo esto
igual 2 x + 1 aquí tengo x al cuadrado
más uno que no lo puedo simplificar más
así que lo paso como esta x al cuadrado
más uno pero aquí también
aquí también tengo una diferencia de
cuadrados esto es una diferencia
cuadrados por lo tanto lo puedo
factorizar como x + 1 por x menos
y creo que así px ya está bastante
bastante factor izado creo que ya no se
puede factorizar más así que p de x es
igual a esto y la razón por la que
quería descomponer apede x en sus
factores es porque si quiero que p de x
sea igual a 0 para algún valor de x eso
equivale a que todo este producto hacia
cero y eso pasa si solo si alguno de
estos factores es cero
así que vamos a analizar cuando se hacen
cero esos factores
comencemos con el primero 2 x + 1
digamos que quiero hacer que 2 x 1 sea
igual a 0 entonces qué tiene que pasar
pues si restó uno de ambos lados o sumo
menos uno tengo que 2x tiene que ser
igual a menos 1 y consecuentemente
dividiendo entre 2 obtengo que x es
igual a menos un medio así que si x es
igual a menos un medio este factor de
aquí es 0 y por lo tanto pd un medio de
menos un medio es 0 así que esta es una
raíz de mi polinomio
bien ahora vamos con x al cuadrado más 1
este polinomio no tienen raíces reales
les voy a explicar por qué si considero
o trato de hacer que x al cuadrado más 1
sea igual a cero entonces necesariamente
tendría que x al cuadrado tiene que ser
igual a menos 1 pero no hay ningún
número real cuyo cuadrados y el número
negativo por lo tanto este factor
me daría soluciones complejas por lo
tanto lo puede ignorar ahora estos
últimos dos factores que pasa pues
cuando es x más uno igual a cero x más
uno es igual a cero si y sólo si sumando
menos uno ambos lados x es igual a menos
uno por lo tanto x es igual a menos uno
también es una raíz de este polinomio
y qué hay de x1 pues x1 es igual a cero
sí y sólo sí
x es igual a 1 por lo tanto aquí tengo
otra raíz vamos a checarlo en el sitio
tengo que las raíces están en menos 1
menos un medio y 1
bien entonces las raíces estaban en
menos 11 en menos un medio y en 1 vamos
a checar la respuesta muy bien ahora
solo quiero dejar algo muy en claro a
pesar de que dije que factorizar este
polinomio es algo así como un arte vamos
a ver que hay distintos modos de llegar
a la respuesta que no es algo así como
magia vudú que simplemente se da veamos
por ejemplo podríamos tener a p de x
escrito pero no en orden descendente en
el grado de de los mono mios sino podría
estar escrito como no sé 2 x a la quinta
menos 2 x más x a la cuarta menos 1 y en
este caso que hubiera pasado pues para
empezar podríamos de aquí factorizar 2 x
éste tiene un factor de 2x y esto
también así que vamos a escribir estos
primeros dos términos como 2 x x
si factor hizo 2x de 12 quizá la quinta
me queda x a la cuarta menos 1
y después tengo este más déjenme voy a
reescribir esto como 1 por equis a la
cuarta menos 1 y noten como aquí ya
apareció en los dos lados y entonces eso
me permite eso me permite factorizar x a
la cuarta de aquí y de acá factorizar lo
traerlo al frente y escribir esto como x
a la cuarta menos 1 x
porque aquí tengo 2x y ya que tengo más
1 que es esencialmente lo que teníamos
antes de nuevo esto es una diferencia
cuadrados y regresaríamos a esta misma
situación así que hay varios caminos que
nos llevan a la misma respuesta así que
bien como resumen la idea es tratar de
utilizar la propiedad distributiva la
mayor cantidad de veces posibles para
que nos empiecen a aparecer cosas
similares que podamos utilizar para
continuar factor izando el polinomio
aquí es la propiedad distributiva me
aparecieron estos dos que eran iguales
así que los factores etcétera etcétera
pero sí admito que esto es algo que
podríamos decir es un arte es algo que
requiere intuición y práctica sobre todo